if we have such respect and reverence
for the insights of shamanism
then we are going to have to take
seriously
a fairly confounding notion to our
materialist
point of view which is when you smoke
dmt
you encounter souls
that in fact death has no sting
and that the metamorphosis
of conscious life occurs
beyond the grave and i resisted this for
years i just pushed it away
as too weird better they should be
extraterrestrial
mean traders come here to do
x y and z better it should be a parallel
continuum
but shaman worldwide insist
that they are the ancestors what can we
bring to bear against that
500 years of scientific rationalism that
has produced an
erotic world population and a toxified
planet
if we you know this is where the
humility
comes in i think we have to seriously
consider
the possibility that uh as mercilead
says
in his wonderful study shamanism the
archaic techniques of ecstasy
he says the shaman is one who can pass
through the same gate that the dead pass
through
every day but the shaman returns
the shaman returns well
this just raises the hackles on the back
of my neck
because now we're beginning to get
answers this
is not instant psychotherapy
this is not an elaborate form of
self-indulgent
play this is getting down to the most
bedrock stuff there can possibly be
we are gaining insight within our own
intellectual constructs
into what lies beyond the grave
and maybe it's because i've always been
obsessed with lepidoptera and have spent
many years observing them but
the butterfly even to the greeks was the
symbol of
psyche the butterfly is the symbol par
excellence of metamorphosis
and so i think that what we
are on the brink of learning as a
culture
is that our terror of death
is a misapprehension of how the universe
works
i mean we're like
contemplating pupation and saying
my god nothing could be worse no longer
will i chew on the cabbage leaves no
longer will i spend my time
moving around on the underside of
foliage
instead something horrible and
unimaginable i don't want to become
a chrysalis and lie still
and exhibit no sign of life and the
caterpillar never notices
unless there are shaman caterpillars
that
what are these miraculous creatures
moving through the air
in a cloud of exultant iridescence
it is the human soul and the mystery
of human becoming you know what is the
basis of hope
the basis of hope is that the teaching
of teachings of shamanism
is that death is an illusion of the
material
mind and that life is
as the buddhists the zongchan people
the shamans as all the old old
earth-centered rooted philosophies teach
life must be a preparation
for the transition to another dimension
[Music]
you